[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like Brandon Shaw if you ain't
thick please don't get involved
now Brandon
what is up fam it is Monday morning
February 20th it's President's Day
so take a second to honor your
Presidents and then just kind of move on
with your day you know that's about it
maybe cook a nice little meal for the
president see what some of their
favorite meals is uh Trump's was hot
dogs I know that he loved hot dogs
bidens is graham crackers and soup
so yeah cook accordingly fam cook
accordingly fresh off the plane from
Naples shout to Naples Florida I could
live there but there's so many old
people it makes me sad outside that I
could definitely live there the
Hurricanes might be an issue
uh before we jump right into this heavy
balls deep in Jake Paul and Tommy Fury
episode
um a few housekeeping notes I am all
over California this week performing uh
starts Tuesday night at The Comedy Store
in the main room and then Thursday night
I'm in Bakersfield I'm in Bakersfield
one night only there are 30 tickets left
for that one show in Bakersfield uh
that's where the band corn was born so
shout out to Bakersfield I know nothing
else about Bakersfield I think uh now I
was gonna say Chuck Liddell was kind of
over for not really it's more of a corn
thing and I'm not talking about the
vegetable the band corn is from
Bakersfield and now your boy's there
that's all I know about Bakersfield but
one night only one show
um that's Thursday night and then
Pasadena the ice house is finally open
your boy is doing a shop and Friends
Saturday night one show only 10 p.m
February 25th Trevor Wallace Adam Ray
very special guest that is at the Ice
House the new ice house is finally back
up and running so that goes down this
Saturday the March 3rd one night one
show only uh March 3rd two shows one
night at the magical Brea Improv and
then uh March 9th through the 11th I'm
in Oklahoma Oklahoma city that is bricks
down Comedy Club so come get you some
now the reason why I only have one March
3rd is on March March 4th with a very
special fight campaign for UFC 285 Jon
Jones return I couldn't miss that and
this Sunday we have a very special cow
bass fight companion I think it starts
at 11 A.M it's 11 A.M here because we're
fighting Saudi Arabia 11 A.M here uh
Pacific Time on thick boy YouTube you
have Cowboys fight command for Jake Paul
Tommy Fury and we have some very special
guests which I will announce on my
social media as we lock these peeps up
but that goes down this freaking Sunday
it's gonna be a fun one Tommy Fury Jake
Paul somebody's o has got to go even
though there's only about 14 fights
between two of them still somebody
though has got to go so let's jump right
on in kids you got Jake Paul Tommy Fury
is finally coming to fruition and it
happens this Sunday in Saudi Arabia
this fight's an easy one for me to break
down this is uh you're talking about two
Polar Opposites you're talking about two
gentlemen who are undefeated and
um one is a power puncher the other is a
finesse uh footwork type of dude one of
them has gone eight rounds with a high
level Fighter the other hasn't gone past
four
um they are both undefeated but
um to me if you look at the tale of the
tape here Jake Paul is going to be maybe
he's an inch taller he's a little
heavier and they're both Orthodox the
thing about this whole fight is you have
a straight up power puncher that doesn't
use a lot of footwork versus a kind of a
pretty boy who uses footwork is not a
power puncher punches in volumes and
hates when the fight gets dirty and also
has some cardio issues with only going
four rounds
um
don't get it twisted there's a reason
Jake Paul has been chasing Tommy Fury
all over this world to get this fight
this fight was this the third or fourth
time supposed to happen you know in Jake
Paul's last money putting promotional
dollars into it and Tommy Fury saying
his ribs hurt or he can't get in because
of immigration whatever reason he came
up with which I don't buy
um and I have no animosity towards Tommy
uh Fury in any facet I actually enjoy
the guy loved him on uh uh love Island
that he's the best guy on there and with
his shout out to Molly made his wife and
uh baby mama so I have no issues with
him I just think this comes down to
they're both inexperienced but when you
look at an experience
um you I always look who's tougher who
wants it more and I think this is clear
as day Jake Paul wants to fight more I
actually think there's more pressure on
Tommy Fury with his background uh with
the fury name his brother being the best
heavyweight to ever do it his dad and
his brother I think advised him against
this fight and you know there's some
kind of back talk there but why he
didn't make the fight happen earlier so
I actually think there's a lot more
pressure on Tommy fury because he comes
from boxing royalty he's not very battle
tested
um you look at some of his opponents now
people say well he has you know two more
fights Than Jake Paul yeah yeah there's
that let me do you a favor here so I've
heard of like warming up like it is an
amateur or even as when you start off as
a pro boxer there's warming up and then
there's Tommy Fury's record let me just
go through it now if you just casually
box for a workout and kind of do it you
tell me how you would do against Tommy
Fury's strength of schedule with his
opponents so his first fight was in 2018
they got ready the guys
10 102.
might not be for you I don't know who
who am I to say I might get hate keep
doing your thing man so then wait you
know what that was a tough fight it was
a tough fight you went off points let's
step it up a notch let's step it up like
I had a lot of experience and you still
beat him off points remember these are
only four round fights his next fight
the guys
oh and 26.
again I don't know if he should continue
boxing but who am I to say he's still
doing the damn thing he's oh and 26. he
won that via KO hell yeah dude you got
it done uh he got did it with body shots
now Tommy Fury in no facet anyone who
has an eye for boxing is going to say
this guy is a power puncher in any
freaking facet he punches in volume he
wants to stay outside he hates when he
gets dirty this is a nightmare of a
matchup for Tommy Fury so right so you
had 10 uh you fought a guy who was 10
102. all right beat him then he find a
guy who's 0 and 26 he beat him like all
right dude we gotta step it up now
you're gonna fight this guy ready
there's two and 26.
all right and they beat him
he beat him he beat him remember he's
only four rounds and then they went you
know what dude you didn't look your best
there you didn't lick your bass there so
why don't we uh why don't we fight this
guy he's Owen 11.
okay so in just going to going through
these opponents the ones I've lift off
these four uh they have uh 12 wins and
124.
uh 150 they're they're 12 and 150 in his
first four fights again I'm all about
starting a guy a slow they're slow and
then there's just moonwalking through a
career uh so he goes on 11 though it all
right you know it is a doctor stopped in
a second we want to see a little more
out of you
you're gonna fight Scott Williams who's
0-9
okay
um
so then he beat him
um and then he fought a guy who was 2-0
uh and it went to decision and then uh
he fought a guy and this was the most to
me the most alarming fight
um
he fought a guy in Anthony Taylor who's
an MMA guy so you know the fury family
wants to talk [__] about MMA guys in the
Box Community once talked about MMA guys
coming over to boxing you guys should be
thanking your boxing stars that MMA guys
are interested in your sport and are
coming over and bringing eyeballs into
your dying sport nobody's watching the
only reason that you guys are hating on
this because the sweet sides I get it
and I respect the hell of it and I love
boxing but you guys should be grateful
that these young kids with a huge fan
base are coming over and just clear
bringing boxing back to life who else is
doing it Tommy Fury for sure not really
I guess you you could hate on him
because he's fighting this mag tune and
doesn't have the experience which I
don't hate another guy for that what
would you do if you were Tommy Fury or
Jake Paul of course you want all the
eyeballs all the money but think about
the stars in boxing there's not a ton of
them there's not a ton of them so you
should be grateful that these guys are
bringing eyeballs to the sports that's a
different conversation but the most
alarming fight to me for Tommy Fury is
you know them hate on MMA guys he fights
guy and Anthony Taylor Anthony T-Rex
Taylor this is no shade at Anthony
Taylor he gave him a hell of a fight
um he looked awful he looked awful it's
a bit of a clash of styles again Tommy
Fury wants to sit outside and look
pretty throw Jabs use footwork
then this is a huge jump but he's
similar to his brother where they're not
knockout artists they're they're going
to sit on the outside and they're throw
Combos and they want long flowing
punches and they're always punching
about 60 percent you never see a heavy
you know 80 90 100 percent throw to
knock a guy out it's just not what they
do they would rather sit outside
um especially in Tommy sit outside and
make it cute
and when you fight a guy like Anthony
Taylor sure to reach
um more of a brawler the fight is really
ugly well
Jake Paul does not want to sit outside
Jake Paul isn't known for his footwork
Jake Paul is going to be in his grill
for eight rounds now we've seen Jayco
eight rounds I think the farthest that
time of fear has gone is five rounds
that right chin I think he went five
rounds in his last fight
his last fight uh cut over the left eye
down once in the fifth round so I'm
pretty sure uh one two three four five
six let's take a look I'm pretty sure
he's only gone five
five rounds and he and his cardio
doesn't look good and good so they
stopped in the six so yeah he's gone
five he didn't fight the sixth round so
he's gone five prior to that it was uh
four rounds one round two rounds four
rounds five rounds this is an eight
round fight we've seen Jake go eight
rounds and as a power puncher be able to
withstand you know the issues with being
a power puncher getting tired and still
be able to face adversity like you did
in Andrew and Silva and still continue
to be able to fight and still have power
like he did when he knocked down Ashton
Silva late in the rounds Anderson Silva
compared to Tommy Fury is apples and
oranges it's not even close how much
more of a better boxer engine service
than Tommy Fury now he's younger but um
it's just stylistically don't get
twisted one of the reasons why Jake and
his brother are so good is everything is
calculated he's been running chasing
Tommy Fury down for damn near over two
years now to get this fight because
stylistically out of anybody that he's
fought anybody he's a perfect match-up
form he's labeled as a boxer so checks
out box you guys have been crying about
he's not finding boxers well I guess
here's a boxer you know his first four
fights their total records 12 and 150
but here's a boxer a guy who doesn't
come from MMA only focus on boxing watch
what happens to your boxer I would be
willing to bet if anybody out there
wants to take this bet Jake knocks him
out in under four rounds because the
thing is is Tommy might be able to do
his thing with his footwork and get you
know land some good combos it doesn't
matter Jake's been hit harder by way
tougher guys so he might be down a round
or two going into the third maybe going
into the fourth
but Jake can trade three Tommy Fury
punches for one of his all Jake needs is
one open shot to land Fury can land as
many as he wants it's not going to
affect the fight it's just not he
doesn't have power he wasn't born with
power now is Tommy does Tommy Fury do
some things better than Jake Paul and
boxing absolutely he grew up boxing is a
much more established amateur background
his brother's also the best heavyweight
to ever do it his dad was a fighter so
he grew up in that atmosphere his
fundamentals are better but when it
comes down to it I would be willing to
bet on Jake Paul over Tommy Fury I just
think a Jake's tougher B stylistically
it's a nightmare for Tommy Fury he wants
to sit outside and look cute Jason get
in your grill he's very good at dirty
boxing he has power inside that uh close
range and he has way more Knockouts with
less fights I think Jake is easiest day
gets it done the I'm sure nerves is
going to be there but I'm willing to bet
on uh Tommy Fury not being able to last
eight complete rounds with Jake Paul who
has better cardio hits harder and has a
better mentality for the sport he just
checks every box over Tommy Fury there's
a reason he's been chasing this dude
down you're going to see it come this
Sunday morning at 11 A.M on thick boy
YouTube on Cal bass fight companion
where I only stand up and sharing
watching Jake Paul not Tommy Fury
unconscious I would bet money on it this
doesn't go to decision if it is it's
just from Tommy running like a crazed
man and Jake's just landed shots and
chase him down ends up winning you know
like six rounds of two or some [__] but
I'd be willing to bet he knocks him out
knocks him out cold and I bet you
they're friends I bet the the fury
family and the Paul's they're it's all
good because they'll respect that but
yeah he's gonna knock him out
let's take a little break from me
chatting here off about Tommy Fury and
Jake Paul because my friends at Green
Chef they've expanded their menu now
choose from over 30 recipes weekly with
the option to mix and match meals from
different
diets whatever you're on all right I'll
come the same box without changing your
plan you can order vegan one day keto
the next they got it all for you I
filled up with the protein packed it's
their newest collection of recipes fit
for a high protein diet with my
psoriasis your boys only eating protein
I'm eating meat right now green Chef
recipes feature premium protein seasonal
organic produce and they have great
Seafood expand your palate with the
unique farm fresh ingredients like figs
dates artichokes green Chef is the only
meal kit that is both carbon and plastic
offset we offset 100 of our carbon
footprint as well as 100 of the plastic
in every freaking box 100 of our Seafood
meets the Monterey Bay Aquarium Seafood
watch rankings of certified Best Choice
or good Alternatives with green Chef
you're reducing your food waste by up to
38 versus grocery shopping we got you
covered man you want to start living a
healthy life it's all about your diet so
go to greenchef.com that's green chef
c-h-e-f.com
shop 60 use code shop 60 to get 60
percent off plus free shipping all right
that's greenchef.com shop 60. the number
one meal kit for eating well
greenchef.com shop 60. this episode of
the shop show is brought to you by happy
hippo that's right happyhippo.com you
get the best Kratom on planet Earth I
reached out to happy hippo I've been a
big Kratom uh supporter for a long time
but you can't just trust anyone you got
to believe what's in these little
containers there's multiple ways to get
your Kratom I do it with these shots
this is the Kratom shot all right
they're highly freaking concentrated
shots of pure Kratom this one is Apple
my favorite is the new butterscotch but
if you don't like them they have pills
for you they got powders they got
gummies however you want to get your
Kratom into your body do it with happy
hippo happyhippo.com promo code is
thick23 thick with three C's
t-h-i-c-c-c 23 three you get 20 off the
entire site again powders gummies pills
the shots that I use I personally
reached out to have people to work with
me because I love their product and here
we are
happyhippo.com promo code is thick 23
thick with three C's you save 20 for
Life use as many times you want share
with many friends as you want kratom's
the gift that keeps on giving listen
I've tried everything I've tried
everything to fire this brain up you
guys know I need the help and I've never
felt better when I'm on Happy Hippo
Kratom right that's Happy hippo.com
promo code stick23 20 off phone life
let's get back to the program it's just
a nightmare of a style for uh Tommy
Freer to deal with there couldn't be a
worse matchup at this level don't get
twisted obviously canel or some [__]
like that would actually mop the floor
both these guys at the same time I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about
that where he's at in his career with
the huge gaps he has in his boxing game
Jake Paul poses the most difficult
challenges for him and Jake Paul has a
lot riding on this and I would be
willing to bet Jake knocks him out in
under four rounds
you excited for it Chad of course man we
went for this for a while yeah and I you
know there's
uh Jake's still not gonna get his credit
even after he knocks him out it's just
not gonna work because he you know if
before Jake came along Tommy fear was
getting the Jake Paul of the actual box
Community came from a reality show right
grew up with a you know Silver Spoon in
his mouth you know he was huge on that
reality show he was known more for that
than he was for his boxing so even
though his brother is the greatest ever
do it and he's huge over there in
Manchester and just the UK in general so
no one gave him credit either so they're
both dealing with those demons I just in
fact a bet on just share toughness I'm
betting as you guys would call them the
Disney kid I think Jake has some demons
and he's unbreakable man he's
unbreakable at this point in his career
and the level that he's fighting he's
unbreakable and his I know they're not
real boxers do you understand what
Woodley or what freaking uh Andrew Silva
would do to any opponent that Tommy Fury
has fought it would be embarrassing so
for Jake to pass those tests and after
seeing how Tommy Fury performed against
T-Rex Taylor this one's an easy pick for
me I know I'm biased Jake's your boy
yeah whatever I'm telling you man there
couldn't be a worse matchup for Tommy
Fury at this level
uh uh Gennady Golovkin stuff like that
Terence Crawford even though the smaller
the obviously even tank Davis being
waste one obviously those are a
nightmare of a matcha form I'm saying at
this level where the guy with six fights
anybody with under 15 fights they're
gonna be a worse matchup for him unless
some big Prospect coming out of the
Olympics I'm like that I'm not talking
about I'm talking about coming from
their backgrounds at this level with
their experience and they obviously they
have room to improve both of them do but
at this stage of the game it's not even
close how much better of a boxer Jake
Paul is than Tommy Fury hate to tell you
guys you can hate on it all you want Oh
but he's just doing this for what he can
make he can play chess and make money
you don't give a [__] he has enough
money already he could race cars he
could have a TV show collecting bunny
rabbits and he'd make money but he chose
to box and since he chose the Box
unfortunately for Tommy Furies and
getting knocked out on live television
Sunday under four rounds coming in hot
and by the way when he when he killed
tying Woodley that's when I think most
people well me at least for sure thought
he was legit his fight with Anderson
Silva knocking him down the Anderson one
did for me yeah and then there's you
know that stupid video that's going
around like oh it's barely straight yeah
you look at the other angle we put it on
the on on this podcast you could see the
actual hit blah Mohammed said it best I
don't know where he got it maybe he made
it up but when the hate doesn't work
they start to tell lies
so the hate that never it doesn't affect
Jake Paul's numbers most people that
hate never works online because it's not
real and then they start to tell lies
it's not working so they come up with
something else so for Jake it was like
okay man he beat [__] s and Sylvie
out Boston for eight [__] rounds not
drop down oh it's fake right it's always
just it's fake it's fake because you
have to tell lies because the Hate's not
working it keeps him bigger he keeps
getting better at boxing so they have to
start telling lies they have nothing
else to do just the way hate goes
loser's gonna lose so he had they got to
come with that narrative oh it's fake
okay so if he knocks out Tommy fearing
under four you think Tommy signed up for
that you think Tommy's gonna ruin his
reputation in the [__] United Kingdom
to get knocked out by Kid Cubs from the
Disney Channel you think he's in on it
which and again these losers will be
like it's fake okay so then what happens
when he fights Nate Diaz or Conor
McGregor is that fake as well what's
fake you think if time to Fury to pull
out and Mike Perry steps in do you know
Mike Perry you think you can give Mike
Perry a script and he's gonna follow it
he has a tattoo on his face
Mike coe's gonna try and rip your head
off so yeah when the hate doesn't work
they start to tell lies
that's how it goes it's about Maria
that's bummer it never keeps it never
holds its worth they just you can't stop
won't stop
you had a big UFC this weekend now big
for one of the matchups you had uh in uh
blanchfield versus Jessica and Josh
should have been a tougher fight for uh
Aaron but man she looked good straight
up
straight up Contender now oh my God
she looked fantastic bummer see Jim
Miller go out like that huh tough fight
Hernandez it's just you know the tides
are turning there's a lot of guys that
are that we grew up loving and I fought
I thought with his brother on a card I
don't know if I've ever fought on SIM
card as Jim Miller but he's been doing
for a hot second you know hot second but
you know these guys cowboy and all these
other guys are retiring could be like
there's a Changing of the Guard man
they've done it long enough and they've
proved himself at least Jim Miller
didn't get like no he's always toughest
face down ass up no no he's a Savage
dude you look at the guys he's beat he
beat Charles Oliveira twice
yeah I mean he's been doing for a hot
second yeah
you look at OSP he didn't look like he
wanted to be in a fist fight
no there's two people on this fight that
did not seem like they wanted to be
there that's what I want to ask you
about too because remember I remember
you mentioning before like you were in
the locker room and you're like I just
don't want to be here yeah I don't want
to go out there yep so it seemed like
OSP and also William Knight that just
jacked dude that was just getting lead
kicked all night
I worked at Hooters for sure man Hooters
yeah man Hoots yeah he didn't look like
he want to be in there uh I mean OSP
didn't either he and you know knocked
down 49 seconds but osp's been known for
hot OSP started when I started damn ice
cream low speed back in the day you know
he was a football player from Tennessee
so you know when you're doing that long
you know and you're out of the running
to really you know do something yeah
a great guy though really good guy
but um yeah but yeah in uh Blanche field
looked she looked amazing phenomenal
yeah
yeah man that's it Doug
she should get a Top Shot next I'll
assume you don't you don't just she
called out uh Valentina like who the
hell calls out her you don't walk
through Jessica and Josh and then not
get a title shot I'm just gonna drive as
tough as they come
she looked great her transition in the
back was filthy take down filthy super
good
um so dude I didn't realize this but the
uh the bare knuckle the bkfc over the
weekend was probably the most exciting
card over the weekend look at the look
at the finishes it's like one decision
and the rest of them are chaos yeah they
don't have gloves on June I was dude I
don't care dude you see Greg Hardy
getting knocked out I did it was such a
bad knockout people were like you know
just grant because with his background I
get it you know you put your hands on a
woman people do not put up with that
unless you're dating like um but with uh
Greg Hardy people were so happy to see
him get locked up but that comes with
the territory right it you know
completely different with Jake Paul you
know how happy people would be if he got
knocked down so there's just this
animosity towards certain Fighters now
Jake Paul didn't doesn't deserve that
he's just living his best life and
bringing eyeballs to the sport and doing
at his pace and making more money than
everyone that triggers people like you
didn't earn it sure whatever
um but with Greg Hardy
you know when you have that dark
background I do believe in forgiveness
you know from what I hear from all his
trading partners everything he's a good
dude just wants to learn you know and he
he did get cut from the EOC
and in the UFC and take it from me I
know this there's not enough hours in
the day to make up the holes no matter
how talented you are how good you are
how athletic you are to once you get to
that top tier guys they've just seen it
all you just experiences is so key there
so with Greg Hardy of course his UFC run
was going to be tough you'll see let him
go he's gonna try and fight his way back
and then he gets in bkfc he took this on
short note notice I think he weighed
295.
and he was a pretty big favorite in this
fight and he got it now it didn't look
awful of the punch like we've seen
harder punches that dude he's fighting
uh is there
it looks like a Jeff Munson type of
character
is this left hook yes or yeah I was left
hook boom 295 man
he's just pointed out people are crunk
about this
yeah that's how it goes um bare knuckle
gonna bare knuckle let's take another
little break because this episode of the
shop show is also brought to you by on
it on it supplements on it.com shop 10
off the entire freaking site whether
you're looking for Alpha Brain Alpha
Brain Black Alpha Brain Focus shot Alpha
Brain instant putting 10 ounces of cold
water boom you're freaking Steve Jobs
they got krill oil joint oil protein
powders viru tech for immune Health
which your boy has to take with my
psoriasis they have all sorts of things
to get your body in Peak condition their
Fitness Gear streaming Gear with Alpha
Brain so someone in Tropic on the planet
you can get at Walmart but help your boy
out go to audit.com shop for 10 off
um and they give you your money back
guarantee if you don't like it keep the
Alpha Brain share it with a friend you
get your money back you don't need to
send the product back go ahead and keep
it but they're gonna refund your money
but there's Alpha Brain then there's
Alpha Brain Black that's for the real
doers the real go-getters Alpha Brain
Black is highly concentrated Alpha Brain
and it's Alpha Brain and then some it's
that secret sauce out for brain Alpha
Brain Black that's what your boy losing
boy uses it's the Black Label Alpha
Brain it is the only nootropic I use it
is the best nootropic on the planet
they've sold over a million bottles of
the regular Alpha Brain but if you're
trying to step your game up if the if
you've been using Alpha Brain like I
have for over eight years you need a
little pep in your step Alpha Brain
Black Label and then I also like the
inside out for brains the shots they're
great on it.com shop temps off the
entire site including Alpha Brain Black
Alpha Brain instant Alpha Brain Focus
shot and irregular nootropic the number
one seller regular Alpha Brain audit.com
shop 10 off now let's get back to the
program
and then your boy Diego Sanchez I think
um these commissions the organizations
are going to try and capitalize Diego
Sanchez you know one of the goats he's
you know he's the first ballot Hall of
Famer but I think the commissions who
allow him to continue fighting should oh
that too they should press charges
against them yeah because a fighter
especially a guy of his Mac dude they're
not gonna stop man they're just built
different so it's so easy for the public
go I don't get why he keeps doing I know
he didn't stop you got to realize that
dude is if this was back in the day he's
a Spartan he doesn't know anything else
that's all the only thing that makes him
happy is competing and punching people
in the face he doesn't want to do
anything else but you have to have some
sort of legislation some sort of
commission go enough no we know you love
it you maybe be a coach do something
enough
because you're going to pay for this
down the road
there should be [__] there should be
charges brought against people it's
ridiculous
yeah and then and for these Fighters out
there why don't you guys going to
realize the commission the CEOs the
presence of these companies that you're
working for that you're fighting for
don't give a [__] about your health dude
they're gonna squeeze every dime out of
you that they can and when you start
having issues later in life go ahead and
try and call them let me know how it
goes for you they don't give a [__] man
what's up no I'm just saying slap
fighting that's a perfect example they
don't give a [__] oh that I mean that
they actually they pass the commission
like how the hell is that possible
that's I mean it's clear they're just
it's just these huge red flags for
Fighters like hey man you got to take
care of yourself build a business
outside of it you got you get this slap
fight
is that is that going to prove the point
is bkfc letting these guys fight you
know at what point are you guys gonna
realize you're on your own man you got
to get a close-knit team around you let
you know it's time to walk away then
also help you so you can focus on
fighting because you gotta have both
feet in but they're building stuff
outside for you you know
yeah
I'm with uh remember when Rogan was
talking about like bare knuckle fighting
how it's better it's safer because
there's not you know because your hands
are weaker without the the glove and the
wrapping stuff if bkfc actually didn't
allow them to wrap their because they're
still wrapping their hands right their
their wrists are stronger and everything
so if they just let it be straight up
bare knuckle I wonder how that would be
if it'd be safer or not it's just tough
It's just tough and they're not seeing a
lot more broken wrist stuff like that's
what I'm saying you're not going to
punch as crazy right maybe it It's just
mma's tough enough to to sell to the
public and they've done a good job of it
but you start going bare knuckle then
slap fight I think the commission or the
Congress kind of thing like hey TPS yeah
so what are you doing what's next yeah
yeah but look I'm with you though it's
it's about money obviously how could
they let the slap you have no defense
and I just understands about money and
you have some sponsors on that but
I mean the with the views
that this is not good we're doing well
on Tick Tock I'm like you know how I
know you're losing
but but we're in hella views on Tick
Tock hey let me talk to you you're 60.
right you're 60.
I don't know how old he is
but uh yeah
anyway we all agree that slap funny is
just it doesn't make any sense
um so this is the so Diego Sanchez is
saying that he might take legal action
against Austin Trout's team again for
this not surrounded by good people so
the the team I guess the cut man or the
cut man and then his coach the the pass
around Vaseline
and then the coach put according to what
I read the coach put some Vaseline on
the back of Austin Trout's neck because
you know Diego's a freaking MMA fighter
you do clinches and stuff right it's
gonna slip so he did that put on his
back and then they in between rounds
they put a vaseline on Austin Trout's
face is that illegal or illegal I don't
remember that should be illegal it is
just legal in UFC too yeah okay should
be fine right face is fine
but this part is not and this is uh some
uh Twitter guy named Ryan gulfoyle okay
posted this and I'll play it for you
real quick
much much
putting Vaseline in this dude's hands
put it on the neck
so Diego Sanchez cannot clearly clinch
because it'll be too vest you know
greasy and slippery
cheater
[Music]
he's not really put on very thick no so
I fast forwarded the video but he did
the guy had Handles in Vaseline and put
on his hands like this and then he
rubbed it on his neck and his back yeah
that's crazy I don't care
[Music]
yeah sure did you watch the fight at
least on his problems I didn't watch the
fight yeah I did at least pops yeah okay
yeah he played Vaseline yeah that's not
cool still you know I'm glad that you're
giving the say because I thought I'm
sure you'd be like no that's the illegal
don't do that [__] definitely don't do
it but also at least of his problems
yeah I didn't see the fight so yeah
you know he lasted four rounds though
but this is how much of course he's as
tough as they come yeah none tougher
dude
he shouldn't be in there um
and then the one I can't show you this
video but I can't we can't put on air
but I'll show you this video this was
insane I tweeted this out oh you did he
knocks him down and I was like yo
homeboy I was like I don't get because I
just thought the knockdown was the video
and then the dude gets so for those of
you just uh listen to the podcast so he
gets clipped gets sat down some bare
knuckle yeah ghost is definitely over he
gets up and other dude's Coming For the
Kill and then just wow instantly out
cool done yeah that was such a that was
such an exciting insane insane and that
was Loren's hot the champion yeah those
were the champion yeah he looked that
was a great comeback
all right so we're not going to show
this but this is also something that
happened at bkfc this girl Carissa she
Twisted her ankle very badly and I'll
show you real quick here
it's insane so this is on this is on
bare knuckle FC's Instagram page you can
see all this stuff
her thing was like completely yeah it it
turned like what 90 degrees and then she
tries to flip it back here as you can
see
she thinks this you can see it pop back
into she's like oh I'm good
and then she tries to get back up don't
put all the weight on that foot though
no I thought the same thing I thought
she's gonna do that but she doesn't but
then watch this right here
so she's getting up and then home you
see it oh my God it's broke it's so bad
yeah
oh my God that was that was horrific
yeah anyhow
that was uh Carissa cigarette is like
you got this
hey man
um all right so we've kind of touched on
this already is on makashiv and the IV
conspiracy
did you know that Fighters can't get IVs
um so I had to read about that to figure
it out me too only a certain level of
the rule but it's like under three
ounces something like that yeah however
uh this is what novitsky said he's going
off of what the Australian commission
said golden snitch the golden snitch
um he's he's basically saying like yeah
I trust what the the commission's saying
they have no evidence of it so it's fine
however if makachev did receive an IV in
Australia the Australian commission you
can't have anything you can't you have
to like notify them or something you
can't do anything at all so it's illegal
no matter what but didn't they say he
had the IV so Ali Abdel Aziz
posted uh let's see here here and then
Ariel helwani pointed this out so Ali
Abdel Aziz for all those idiots out
there any fighter under the UFC Banner
can take two to three liters of IV as
long as it's done by a nurse or a
professional next week I'm gonna expose
everybody is all Mark Jeff is the pound
for pound King so we deleted this so
he's agreeing that he got it he's
implying that he he could do it so that
means just so you guys know they can do
it and then scroll up to what Ariel put
you're on Elite Ali hate each other by
the way oh okay I think but uh yes he do
it because someone I would think told
him he was incriminating himself with
this tweet you can't take two to three
leaders by a professional or not it's
100 milliliter per 12 hours among other
details massive difference but then we
also found out later that the Australian
commission doesn't allow it at all
so if he did it in Australia he
definitely cheated or he did something
that was against let me ask you
something just Playing devil's advocate
yeah you think the guy that started to
slap Fight League is gonna look into the
investigate this
or do you think it's just gonna be like
ah whatever
let me see what it says first of all the
Burma proof is on the person to make the
accusations because nobody has to
provide anything yet that shows mock
Jeff took an IV of any size Ali who I
actually like Ali put brother these
people make stuff up is shocked me as
I'm did not uh did not do any IV even if
you want to we would do it the legal way
so many fighters didn't even know that
they actually can use an IV Wednesday
I'm going to embarrass everybody stay
tuned this Wednesday apparently yeah
this upcoming Wednesday but I mean the
original tweet I don't want to get too
much into it because I don't know what
the hell's going on but it does seem
like yeah he would he did the IV the
correct way yeah it's like there is no
correct way but I mean there's there's
not enough evidence regardless so it's
gonna be hard to prove also you know I
mean the overall message whether he did
it or not I really don't care to be
honest
IV should be legal no matter no matter
what but they're not so it's against the
rules yeah so you can't that's a gray
area
it doesn't change the fact that you know
how you feel about the fight now I I do
think wilkonov's going that fight
judged and give it to him they can run
it back run it back Do It in America run
back Do It in America
um and you maybe you won't have this you
know this kind of Foolery I don't know
you know these commissions are wild dude
but um
as as Islam or I'm sorry as Muhammad
said you know when the hate doesn't work
they make [__] up so I don't know
Casey just texted me this because
there's only a certain amount of people
that actually know what happens
Islam
and whoever was in the room and the
nurse that administrated the IV and
whoever was in that room that's really
it man
vulcry Doesn't Know Dan hooker doesn't
know his own students only people that
know so unless that nurse comes out and
say yeah I gave him this B6 but a lot of
the calcium all that [__] and I doubt
she will I mean she's a traitor
especially she's Australian right Trader
shipper over to Dallas that right let's
find out who that is and ship her out of
that goddamn country am I right
Australians
uh Brett akamoto put there seems to be
misunderstanding across the sport on the
prohibited or and non-prohibited use of
IVs I myself was not completely aware of
this until the latest high profile
example accusation from UC to it me
neither I sought further clarification
here's the bottom line if an athlete is
a uh administrated an IV of more than
the permitted 100 million milliliters as
long as it's done by license Pro it's
not a violation even in cases where
dehydrate dehydrations caused by a
weight gut is the issue being treated if
you need IV that bag and that bad and
that middle is gonna like bring you back
to life move up a weight class
in other words I've used used to treat
severe dehydration caused by cutting
weight are not really banned as long as
a physician isn't is the one to just
find perform it but none of this matters
because in the Australian positions I
think this is they say no now that's
four that's for America and I don't know
where else but in Australia yeah for
Brett akamoto none of that matters yeah
from what I read none of that matters
it's just you're not allowed to do it I
think unless you contact usada first and
then and then there's an agreement or
something like that yeah either way it
sounds like those trt days
we're just here to be big enough and
famous enough to get that trt
by the way check this out dude so I sign
into this account we created this
account in 2017. never really used it
right but the first tweet I saw on there
February it's in February too
February 1st 2017 the first big brown
Breakdown live March 2nd Ice House oh
how crazy is that
Jesus Christ literally on end of
February that was super years ago
six years yeah pretty freaking crazy
that's cool man
all right uh Conor McGregor he posted
this on his Instagram
good this is funny this is an athlete he
got right when he got to tough so he
just got the tough yeah it says uh good
practice team okay it's time for the
easiest part of any coaching's job uh
the cut now I wasn't able to cut
everyone I wanted to I've cut a lot of
you uh Wendell is cut Rudy is cut Jenny
you're gone Stephen I like your hustle
that's why it was so hard to cut you
congratulations the rest of you made the
team except you you and you The Ultimate
Fighter Las Vegas 2023. it sounds so
hard you [__] can you imagine if you go
back up can you imagine if you're Janie
Wendell like look up to Connie like what
the [__]
but he came out and said he cut a bunch
of guys on team for his guys yeah that's
the reason I was like that ain't true I
mean again what I tell you when when the
hate doesn't work they make up lies so
it's all this [__] man uh so this is
from Daniel Rubinstein
so he said Ken cross Mitch Ramirez
Brandon Jenkins all all got pulled off
to make room for three of college guys
to be on the show
that's about being college guy so okay
so Connor did say that that was not the
case like he only knew one of the one of
the guys and then Gilbert Burns we all
love Gilbert Burns he said
hold on here oh this guy got taken off
yeah he said for sure there you go
this guy's my teammate
guys name's tough I know I'm trying pfl
finalists at 55 worked so hard and was
ready to finally get shot and you'll see
on tough was in Vegas feeling good to go
this freaking Connor brings his own guys
and they kick him out not fair but he
put not fear
f-e-a-r I know so makes me tweet a
little English in his first language all
good
but yeah I mean I mean I I think there
might be some truth to it but who knows
the only bummer is like clearly Connor
what's alarming me is Connor's clearly
not paying attention because if he just
gets it he's like who who are these guys
like that's your team he's like ah him
him out there like dude we made the
teams weeks ago where were you then he's
like I don't give a [__] get my guys in
here like that's that's just not paying
attention to details
yeah well you said before Connor get him
out of here he's a powerful guy he could
do what he wants yeah sure the most
profit down this team not named in white
uh we posted this or we talked about
this before how uh Jon Bones Jones is
saying like he's cool with
uh Daniel Cormier comment commentated on
this fight and doing all that stuff and
then this came out
after as well
but in all serious DC I'm cool with you
bro I recognize the manual I wasn't
lying when I said those things in my
post flight interview outside of us
being fish competitors I dig the way you
represent yourself the wrestling
committee our community and our sport
sit down interview post fight interview
coaches meeting we're cool for real I
appreciate your competitive nature you
drove me to be a better competitor
forever grateful that's great very sweet
right and then someone asked him about
doing DC's YouTube channel
hello let's not go too far now yeah
which is weird because that's the
interview true but then also Daniel
cormie finally responded about all this
stuff and then I can break it down for
you once you want to just he says you
get you guys know how I feel about John
uh about Jon Jones and how we have felt
about each other in the past
um but it leads me to this question how
do I take this this is this particular
tweet which at times feels like a
compliment but also it could be
interpreted as a bit of a dig
considering at times people call me bias
my commentary and all that other stuff
first just for the record I don't really
need permission to call someone's fight
I didn't think take it as a dick yeah
later on Samuel's insecurities be like
he gets a dig people say I'm biased and
I'll be honest with you it's kind of
nice hearing fighter uh acknowledge that
even with our history he believes that I
can do him Justice and do the job fairly
because I've done it before it seems now
that John is maturing he seems to be
taking a much different approach to the
build to approach to the build to the
fight and how he's approaching
everything but it feels nice for him to
acknowledge I think this guy could do me
Justice yes it's nice to hear him go hey
man I believe DC can do the job but I'm
professional I have to be able to do the
job I don't know that Jon Jones and I
sit for an interview I don't know if we
sit for a fighter meeting I don't know I
can't answer those questions for you
just yet because I don't know he that he
should that would be I mean yeah and no
one knows John better in DC like that
that's who we need to do it
all right and did and did you hear um
uh Cyril gone he did an interview in
French but then I didn't train much
where he's like yeah the thing about me
is you know I really don't train until I
get the fight that's all
excuse me yeah and I thought for sure
you get like hate on people like man
that's how big of a freak he is I'm like
yeah yeah you can't wrestle or grapple
though I thought he was just working on
his grappling wrestling outside of
fighting like not during Camp nope only
gets ready I can't emphasize enough I
was like oh I'll bet my house on Jon
Jones now you don't grapple and wrestle
outside of camp
hey hey Monsieur you're [__] straight
up dude it's gonna be a tough go for him
in the office you got out grappled by
Francis and he had one leg daddy hmm
he did say because the Jon Jones fight
was so exciting he started to really
train hard for it but okay so you've
been resting for an extra month yeah who
knows I hate hearing that
yeah I mean there you go people like Jon
Jones does I'm like he's not John Jones
all right this is a bit of a
controversial one I know you're you're
homies with the Nate Marquardt back in
the day uh he I guess he posted a tweet
that comes off as homophobic
and uh so let me read this tweet he goes
yes here we go uh so he's watching UFC
fights he goes wow discussing commercial
watching ESPN plus with my kids and I
have to tell them to look away so they
don't see two men kissing hashtag parf
hashtag disgusting yeah pretty
homophobic yeah
um
uh let's say it's not hateful to say
that homosexual pedophilia and uh he put
those together which is kind of crazy oh
wow but homosexuality and pedophilia is
the same thing yeah
it's not longing to be silent when the
culture Praises things that lead people
to Hell interesting then quotes the
Bible it's not hateful but loving to
protect children from this world's evil
demented propaganda
okay Nate Dogg are you from 1923
hey MMA Jane thanks for promoting my
tweet one it wasn't hateful yeah it was
two was it unnecessary a little bit
three ad hominem attacks on me don't
prove your point I'm standing up against
evil in the media where most people are
too scared to get canceled
um someone says how are you grouping all
those together they're discussing sin
worthy of death that's why people need
Jesus death on the cross to save them he
went hardcore double Downing them
um yeah so amen homosexuality is an
attack on society from Satan Jesus
Christ Nate it's the result of people
away from God it's so destructive to
society
I love all people I love them enough to
tell them when their lifestyle will lead
them to hell I love them enough to
offend them and be called a hateful
bigot Jesus said to love your enemies
it's bot loving to let someone drive off
a cliff it's not oh it's not loving
there you go are they talking about like
bots on the Internet it's not loving let
someone drive off a cliff I'm shouting
at them to stop
he's going like just hardcore so
religious and
I don't want to deal with this I mean
obviously I have a relationship with nav
and talked to him in a while he was like
our team captain
it it's it's just so close-minded to you
can be religious but you also have to be
realistic you know that book was written
how many thousands of years ago so
there's nothing wrong with it and it's
it's religion is great for people and
some of the best people I know are
religious
but when they do it like by by the book
because back then you're talking about
different times man so to not be
open-minded against gays or uh you know
transgender stuff like that is insane in
2023. it's just so old school I know
your Bible's telling you one thing but
I think Nate doesn't have the
perspective or
the intelligence to realize some people
are born that way man you think they
choose that life
you think these people are transgender
that get hate and are scared to walk
down the street and some get killed left
and right and forget about America
forget about America try being gay in
Brazil Russia Pakistan China and North
Korea South Korea Japan it's a tough go
dude no one chooses that life it is a
hard go man and thank God America allows
those people to you know walk the
streets freely but even then it's a
tough go for them they don't a lot of
them don't choose that now some might
choose it some might who gives a [__]
but what's it bother you and Nate how
prove to me they're going to hell dude
or do you think you being so judgmental
and hearing these people's feelings and
putting that hateful speech out there is
gonna you think that gets you to heaven
I got news for you buddy and I love Nate
don't don't love this in any facet I
don't associate with people like this
it's not cool it's also 223
then you're out of your mind if you
don't think I have friends who are gay
you think it's okay to hate on those
people think say they're going to hell
that's insane it's 2023 dude
same they deserve death was the harshest
thing I saw was like well looping
together homosexuality and pedophilia is
like oh my God this guy
you have to bleep out that
all right now I now I would be tempted
to say too let's take it a little bit
easy on Nate I'm not co-sign this in any
faster saying it's okay that is not okay
at all ever
I would be not going out on a limb to
say CT has some sort of effect on why
he's doubling down on Jesus he now I've
known Nate for a very very long time he
wasn't always like this a lot of this
came after Knockouts now I'm not saying
he got knocked so hard he got punched so
hard he found Jesus but they're they're
you have to give him some leeway
right you have to be some leeway you
don't throw hate his way because you
hate when you threw hate your way that's
not the way to two wrongs don't make a
right there you have to talk I would
assume sum this up to CT just being
frank with all you guys
but that's insane
that was tough to see it's a bummer
[Music]
yeah
um
yeah I don't want to go too much into it
but yeah
so Alexander volkanovsky he had this
video I think it was on his YouTube
channel about him and microchip after
the fight they both agreed that they
would do a rematch
rematch in Abu Dhabi so that was the
thing they were talking about together
what are you guys doing these [__]
Clips you're in America
yeah that'd be cool too man in Vegas
hell yeah yeah everyone goes to videos
everyone from Every place no shenanigans
uh this is just you know we talked about
this on I think last week's episode how
Deontay Wilder wanted for some reason to
fight Francis agano in boxing and then
boxing gets my day card MMA no no who's
gonna I guess maybe pfl would do it or
they could just do their own promotion
to it but uh friends said welcome to the
Free World bronze bomber I hope you are
a man of your word see you soon
Deontay Wilder was declared that he's
now an open Agent and taking full
control of security said No Bad Blood
I'm still part of PBC I'm just an open
Agent open fighter I want to fight on
all type of platforms I wanted to work
with anyone France said I'll be your
huckle yeah especially for those rule
sets like MMA and boxing he's like yeah
I'm in so he's hoping that Deontay
Wilder's really serious about it but
even if but even if he called I was like
man that's just for the Tweet I'm not
fighting [__] MMA I'll box you know
he's still it's the best chance to beat
somebody at that level Deontay Wilder is
your best chance he's been doing the
least amount of time he just has a huge
right hand he's gonna have a ton of
fundamentals and I love Deonte that'd be
a great fight he's such a great guy I
will never forget how awesome he is yeah
uh this is interesting Bo nickel teamed
up with Jake Paul I guess he signed to
his better
um that that new app that he's doing
whatever so he's he's part of the man
our boy the Schmo
oh there's one too schmo's part of it
too Bo nickels in the Schmo yeah so uh
Bowen echo's gonna apparently help Jake
with wrestling and he's he's hoping that
Jake helps him with striking
yeah it could be good for each other
yeah
but that's cool bonok is like blowing up
now yeah he's crushed it
I don't know if we talked about this but
uh this fight gets my dick hard too yeah
I don't know did we mention this I just
forgot so just in case we didn't for you
yeah
fight UFC 287.
and uh let's move on towards
this is nothing I want to play for you I
don't know if we can actually put online
but everything's on Instagram let's see
it so Conor McGregor put this on his
Instagram on February 6th he's gonna say
some you know exciting news and he was
you know imitating Steve Jobs and I
thought it was gonna be some sort of
connection with Apple
but it was just about proper 12. oh
tight move yes exactly so I thought it
was gonna be an actual level that's
brilliant yeah it is it was Annie is the
green rolly
is do you know much about that girl yeah
Rolex is ridiculous
um yeah tight move it's more of that so
funny yes that's what he said so Paula
Carlson I don't know dude podcast is
like legit funny now
he did a spoof on his spoof so then
Paula Costa did the same thing he teased
it like that there's something you know
announcement gonna be made and then this
is his video
his jeans are so tight he went through
all that trouble to make this video yeah
it's brilliant yeah he's becoming
funnier and funny funnier and funnier
uh let's just do one more
let's do
oh so Bryce Mitchell posted this on his
Instagram I guess he had a splinter in
his ham right
trying to cut out myself and it was
passed out it was buried in my hand doc
just got it I always wear gloves from
now on
and the fights that's three inches yeah
three inches holy [__]
yeah that's pretty much it man
well at least the fight's still on thank
God yeah
is that it he say he's not a [__] yeah
that's it all right kids cow bass fight
campaign this freaking Sunday at 11 A.M
Pacific time you have Tommy Fury versus
Jake Paul with a very special crew which
I will announce on my social media that
is going down this mother Trucking
Sunday 11 A.M Pacific thick boy YouTube
come watch it with the boys should be a
fun one yes from UFC you got a Fight
Night cry live versus Ryan Spann uh but
really the main event should be Tatiana
Suarez versus uh Montana uh Suarez is
your next champion at flyweight I would
bet the bank on it she should be your
main event but she's not but watch your
Molly [__] dela Rosa and uh yeah bkfc
yeah one Championship so you got it if
you're a fight fan hardcore especially
you got a lot of stuff to watch
um yeah touring wise I'm all over LA or
California Tuesday night starts at The
Comedy Store in the main room
um Thursday night I am in Bakersfield
one show only that thing's almost sold
out and then uh Pasadena Ice House the
grand opening the ice house Saturday
shopping friends Trevor Wallace Adam Ray
and very special guests that goes down
at 10 p.m Saturday night at the Ice
House in Pasadena California Brea wants
your only Friday March 3rd two shows one
magical night and then March 4th you
have the special uh kabats fight
companion with jelly roll
uh who else I got I got jelly roll why
am I forgetting somebody oh that's right
jelly roll Rampage and a very special
guest
um that goes down March 4th on thick boy
YouTube for UFC 18 285 with Jon Jones
and then Oklahoma City March 9th 11th
Tacoma Washington won my phase March
23rd through 25th get your tickets for
all the shows at thickboy.com but
um Comedy Store ice house and
Bakersfield you're up next then bran
love you guys tickets at thickboy.com be
nice to each other stay safe I'm out